nous
bien m'écouter vous avez malgré toutes
les manoeuvres des manuels macron pour
faire monter les extrêmes les
républicains sont là sont présents et on
voit bien que nous sommes aujourd'hui le
seul vote utile une position utile qui
sera jamais dans les outrances nez dans
les excès mais qui sera déterminée pour
voter a demandé une réforme qui pour
aller dans le bon sens et pour s'opposer
durement à celle qui rompt à contresens
de ce que l'on veut ce que l'on souhaite
et de ce qui est souhaitable pour le
pays sur notre position elle est
conforme la ligne qui a toujours été
celle de notre famille politique
aucune voix sur le doit se porter sur
l'extrême donc tenu de votre score et le
score d'ensemble est quel rôle vous
pourriez être amené à jouer est ce que
vous payez vont très loin qu'une force
d'appoint
en aucun cas une force d'appoint une
opposition une opposition déterminée
mais une position utile c'est-à-dire pas
dans le blocage des institutions pas
dans les outrances pas pour bloquer le
pays est capable d'amendé des textes
pour les corriger nous avons la majorité
au sénat et ça permet d'avoir le relais
effectivement avec avec le sénat
d'ailleurs on le voit bien la commission
d' enquête sur ce qui s'est passé au
stade de france c'est le sénat qui a qui
a pris la main et nous pouvons jouer ce
rôle déterminant ils vous disent
[Musique]
ça peut être intéressant pour le pays
d'avoir une opposition et il et c'est
sur cette ligne là que nous avons
toujours été le resteront force de
proposition pour corriger les textes
mais je pense que nous serons en
situation de pouvoir le faire
d'accord en interne
d'amendé oui oui j'ai rougi sion que
nous avons pris en conseil stratégique
non c'est pas des accords nous poserons
des amendements des propositions et il
vient après seront retenus où elles ne
seront pas mais nous serons en situation
de faire bouger un certain nombre de
textes et notamment de réformer notre
pays ce qui aujourd'hui vaut sanctions
pour la république en marche c'est c'est
cette politique de l'immobilisme et de
vouloir embrasser large à chaque fois et
on voit bien que nous avons une majorité
immobile pendant cinq ans et nous sommes
en situation de pouvoir faire bouger ça
les ronfleurs à mesure que les textes
viendront la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
le pouvoir d'achat on voit bien la
situation de désespérance dans certain
nombre de circonscriptions de nos
compatriotes c'est aussi sur la sécurité
qui était à l'abandon complet avec une
politique des plus laxistes la même
façon que sur le contrôle de
l'immigration donc pouvoir d'achat
sécurité et puis la santé là aussi rien
n'a été fait dans le même sens dans les
retraites eh bien nous verrons le texte
est proposé nous nous avons toujours une
très claire sur le sujet n'avons jamais
varié dans son emploi n'avons pas
l'intention de l'ariège
dernière vous aviez créé la surprise si
votre pari n'est pas arrêtée par rapport
à ce que vous annonciez il est très
réussie puisque tout serein groupe une
trentaine de députés on voit qu'on sera
bien bien au delà et et je pense qu'on
sera effectivement dans cette situation
d'être des acteurs déterminants elles
sont légères l'a perdu dès la seconde
hystérique dans le loiret calais par
exemple comment nous en gagnons aussi
nous allons gagner dimanche prochain
vous verrez que dans un certain nombre
de régions et de départements nous
sommes en situation de gagner avec des
primes aux candidats trop lourd et ça
s'entend
bien sur
wii mais c'était le cas chaque élection
chaque élection a son lot de surprises
dans un sens ou dans un autre mais nous
avons aussi une quinzaine de
circonscriptions nous sommes en
situation de gagner là où nous n'étions
pas installé
c'est un soulagement a limité la casse
non ces deux c'est de continuer le
continuer le combat d'être utile utile
au pays utile à la réforme nous avons
toujours été et force de proposition et
nous continuons avec
on avait deux députés sortants je pense
qu'on retrouvera nos deux députés qu'est
ce que j'en pense en coupé et hélas non
l'été en serpent c'est parce que comme à
chaque matin avant l'école des
saints-anges il va et télé pour dire
qu'il faudrait tenter avec ma troupe
vous en avez discuté ce que vous vous
êtes nommé louis la ligne est ouvert aux
juges jean françois copé hier soir mais
au-delà de ça la position conseil
stratégique et une année est ce qu'il y
aura donc sa peine situation un soutien
explicite de l air à des candidats de la
majorité pour bloquer une épaisse de rl
en face aucune voix aux extrêmes nous
restons sur notre ligne depuis que le
rpr existe en passant par l'ump les
républicains aujourd'hui n'avons jamais
mariés c'est quoi les extrêmes puisque
la socialiste qui serait investi par la
nuque est un extrême c'est un soutien de
mélenchon ça c'est quoi alors moi je
vous réponds
voix pour le fn
c'est aucune voix ne doit se porter sur
les extrêmes c'est aussi clair que ça
[Musique]